all right Flash
hello flash uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally from San
Francisco
uh you decide to be here
tell me about how you grew up
all right grew up in San Francisco by
Brown Heights uh in the Mission District
basically
and what was it what was your what were
your parents like
uh parents were great I had three
brothers Three Sisters
and uh
uh my dad worked as a machinist American
late night shifts and and my mom just
took care of us
and uh we had a good childhood
if you all got along great
and uh
how about you in school I went there I
graduated high school
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life
yeah
yeah really
what were the who are the role models
that you had your dad or my dad for most
of my life but he moves your dad into
he was a he was a
is it being he was a mechanic I mean he
uh he used to he was in a country
western music he played guitars Gobo and
stuff like that he sometimes he played
nighttime with two of the bars and uh
and we can those areas are part of our
life we never get together and jam with
some of his friends you know playing the
country western music that she was
raised on
so that's pretty cool he was never into
the biker scene oh yeah he was and he he
actually was in what he actually joined
the motorcycle club called the mofos you
know in San Francisco
but you know
the uh Frederick de Los Angeles Angels
these come to my house all the time and
whenever the kid sometimes they even
have meetings there yeah
but uh you're my daddy and
uh
he's a big guy you know
and uh
gentle is the land you know so you're
used to having bikers around the house
yeah
and
or it's been done
it really acted right you know it was we
learned a lot of values from from that
honor integrity and stuff
and uh
that you know remember dad was riding
with them uh
he's my mom went with a few times and
but we were we were kids so we didn't
know much about what they were doing
yeah
working uh later on you know
you know later on when I went to high
school
and uh got a motorcycle that built me on
the
but my first 57th Panhead when I was
just getting over a book of leg
because when I was I was working
stapling boxes as a box company
uh you know we work in a gas station
doing three different jobs in besides
school
and uh
I just wanted to write my you know just
one of my my first day started with
bicycles and my dad one time of year
uh when I was when I was six years old
he had a
TV repair stop shop on uh like hate
street with my grandfather
where he worked on TV to repair and
radios when TVs just first came out
and that's the first time I remember
doing anything I went with him when I
was six years old and he had me taken
apart radios
so I'm sure he had that that shop for a
while and then later on you know
I guess my grandfather died and all that
stuff
so anyway he uh eventually uh
wanted to open another generator repair
store at CB store getting into CVS for
the whole time
and uh so his friend uh offended him his
birthday was wide open this door so they
went and bought the bicycles they bought
this this spot on the registry which is
bicycle store and they the only way to
get the shop in order to get the
building they had to buy the buy out the
inventory
so he ended up bringing home
almost a whole Bicycle Shop full of
bicycle parts
so I ended up working on bicycles for a
few years in my garage just built it for
my friends and fixing them and stuff
like that it was basically the beginning
of my mechanical
history you know you know eventually
ended up being mechanic in motorcycle
mechanic car mechanic
um I was 12 years old waiting for my
grandfather my uncle
in cars and stuff like that because I
could get my hands in spots and the
manual dexterity
so you know yeah
50 cents an hour a lot of money back
then yeah
so that worked for him and you know
uh and later on like you know at the gas
station job and the stapling the the
cardboard
Factory job or stapling boxes
you know steeping them so fast that it
was fasting can be out there the job
before me my boss is so impressed he
started calling me flash
because that was my name Gordon you know
so
that's where I got the name Flash from
and uh
you know I actually doubled their output
and then you're asking every type of
fish here with it she went into
you know I was riding motor scooters and
stuff like that and then I finally got
this a bike thick enough to go on the
freeway I bought that when I was working
the gas station
and I was looking forward to going to be
going to Clear Lake
what you could because you couldn't go
on the freeway with anything they had
less than 15 horsepower so we had to
have
sure I got my bike big enough to do that
you know looking forward to do that when
I was 16 on my way way to work you put
in uh half a day's work and then I was
going to take off and go to Clear Lake
and the doctor had brought into an
intersection
uh this guy ran a stop sign about 45
miles an hour and knocked me out of the
intersection broke my leg in a few
places
I spent the next uh five weeks in
traction and the rest of the rest of the
summer and body cast
see when they got out of the body cast
you know I was in my crutches and my dad
in the meantime uh he had he hadn't been
riding for a while and he wanted to put
another bike together
she had a friend of hers she had a
wrecking yard so my dad used to it was
right there inspectors for 30 days
four weeks vacation that year from for
every year we would go on vacation every
year to Clear Lake you know and when we
do we then finally got the four weeks
vacation this one year he decided the
we're going to Clear Lake he's gonna
work the record yard and get a basket
job so he got the message obviously
motorcycles to all the boxes Parts he's
been able to put it back together used
parts and stuff so he worked for 30 days
doing that and brought him a basket job
meantime my morning crutches I get up on
crutches and previously before I broke
my leg I've been hanging out with some
of the guys who were the Hell's Angels
with friends and my dads and there was
something they're working their bikes
you know he
sure I learned to learn how to look on I
started working on motorcycle yeah
but uh
it's always empty I guess
um somebody uh
so I ended up that they should
settlement for the wreck and they gave
me 500 for the bike you know which is I
could get that right away the other
three thousand I couldn't touch it I was
21.
and uh
it's her anyway but uh with the 500
check
I told my dad to his dad
500 but the baskets are
done deal so I built that bike got it
running started riding motorcycles
there's your first is that a Harley yeah
57 uh Panhead
and there's all used parts and that bike
stayed together for another 20 years
after that but almost every part on it
was changed after 20 years after as I
took the newer Parts better parts and
rebuilding it yeah I learned more and
your bike got better better faster
faster
how did you first join the Hell's Angels
or did that no well I was in high school
and you know I ride my motorcycle to
school
and uh
uh I started a club with some friends of
mine called The Frisco Raiders
and you know we all had
many of these guys ever had their bikes
running we never really had to go
because it really wasn't really going I
was the only one that was riding
but I'll be riding with the uh our
girlfriend riding for the Los Angeles
and you can hang out with some of the
Jokers and stuff like that and uh and uh
I was really close with uh but a couple
of members in the club
and uh
one day I was uh
it's all one of our members uh more in
his name so they weren't guess what when
the Jokers asked me to come join their
Club I said what he said what you don't
do that you're gonna join the real
you're going to join a country and join
the real clubs and they say yes maybe
it's possible because I'm saying I'm 17
years old I mean there's no way I can
feel like that I could actually do that
I just started writing more with them
and then eventually ended up becoming a
prospect and uh I was still in high
school were you the youngest member uh
at the time in San Francisco I mean I
think Sunny might have been the same age
as me when he started to come around
Sonny Barger yeah
but uh
but I get you know you know uh
so much
you know graduated I mean I turned 18.
in March and
and uh
kind of Club in May and graduated from
high school in June
you know did you've been a member now
for how many years yeah almost 56 years
56 years as a Hell's Angel
tell me what
what it was like back that was the 60s
60s
this is in San Francisco yeah back doing
eight Ashbury days you know and uh
I spent a lot of time you know up on 8th
Street with the club and a lot of places
we used to have lots of rides all over
the place you know and there's a lot of
conscious and stuff you know yeah
you know nightlife you know after I go
to school the upper day workout for day
and
I don't know
get credit for it
then I graduated my school and then you
know I understood then they got bullied
in the club
and actually
it's supposed to be 20. they're supposed
to be uh 21 I have ID for 21 but but as
long as they didn't go in the bars they
they didn't care you know 30 voted man
when I was 18.
so
and uh
then a few years later I uh you know
talking about Altamonte
in 1969 was an interesting year that's
when we ended up uh
starting the uh the club over in uh in
England
we had a couple of members that were
connected with the uh
with the scene you know on the aid
aspers and they uh
George Harrison or something like that
and he invited invited the invite us
over to uh
can't do Abby records or whatever
during the show yeah everybody took him
up on it so two of our members Mr
William Bill uh rich and uh Pete now
they've loaded their bikes up and
shipped him over to England he went with
the Entourage a bunch of people from the
uh
their offender of the uh
you know Grateful Dead and stuff like
that
and they went over there and
met with the Beatles and everything but
but they went out and they seen all
these fake fake members all other places
there's a big fad at the time I guess
all kinds of phony house diesels all
over this place so they went and found
the eyes with the most with the big guy
with the best reputation over there and
ended up connecting with him and brought
him back
station for about a year he hung out and
we got to and we ended up
uh
having two charters we started at the
same time in uh in England
because uh
uh and that's and that's now it's
worldwide we over 40 Charters worldwide
how many how many Charters are there
over 400 400 across the country across
the world yeah
yeah and uh you know guys used to come
here all the time and visit from other
countries and we're having a great time
and if we go visit the other countries
too I still go visit other countries
but after 2011
Savannah's FBI and the FED uh Hillary
Clinton and them got US declared
domestic terrorists
without a trial or anything like that
and and definitely that declaration
they've they banned any members from
many other countries from coming to the
United States anymore
so you can't get a Visa because the uh
just because you're by guilt by
association the Hell's Angels are not a
terrorist organization right that's what
they they declared it you know just that
you know how the government is nowadays
and all the stuff they've been doing
everybody they've been doing they've
been practicing on us you know
you know like uh
three years yes so anyway so uh
back to the Altamonte yeah tell me about
Altima okay throughout the month we had
that meeting and it's been uh
said okay we'll do that so anyway then
comes when the day came we checked a lot
of us uh we went there earlier in the
day we were going to find out what
random places laid out and it was a back
way in behind the behind the uh
the equipment and stuff like stage and
everything so that's where most of us
came in parked and we parked our bus
there we had a yellow bus I had the beer
in it
and uh but how did you first get
involved in working Altima we're talking
about because they presented to us that
they wanted us to do this
uh well I don't know if I said it again
or not but but like you started with we
had this meeting at Ken kisses house
with uh Sam Cutler I think it was there
uh anyway uh it was originally supposed
to be at Golden Gate Park yeah they
presented the thing they said they were
going to the the really Soldier we're
having this world tour and they were
going to wrap it up they wanted to
finish it up with a free concert in San
Francisco
they wanted to be for the public for the
people so the Rolling Stones are gonna
do a free show at Golden Gate Park right
and they yeah they said since we're
always on this since you know Colgate
Park is where they used to have lots of
uh love ends and be enjoy their crawling
with big big parties where people put
Advantage playing people would come and
have a great time what year is this 67
68 69. so this is a
uh so they asked us if you know because
you guys are always backstage anyway
uh we're not going to have it we don't
have a barricade we don't want any cops
and security guards and like that if you
can just keep people off the stage
be great that you're always there anyway
I said no problem we do that
and uh and uh you know how much you want
for that here so we don't want any money
for that we're not cops here we're not
security guard do they say do our work
but I had a budget about 500 and
give me some beer said uh okay we'll be
surprising bear said he said okay yeah
about 500 so okay deal so to give us 500
bucks we load the bar there for for the
uh for the bus we already brought that
beer to the Thousand months
and and everything you know
is there anyway so it turns out it
wasn't
back up everything after mine was
supposed to Golden Gate Park but the
city of San Francisco didn't weren't
that many people showing up for that big
event so they canceled the permit so
they had no place to have the uh concert
now they've been short time now for you
before the uh thing was supposed to be
happening
and then they end up finding a spot over
at Sears point up in the Sonoma
and uh they were sent they had it all
set up to have the concert there
and then a couple days beforehand they
turned out that guy pulled a plug on it
because uh they found out they were you
know it's supposed to be a free concert
but but they were if they were going to
be making money when they they weren't
gonna and I guess I guess the uh the
racetrack wanted some money and they
couldn't reach an agreement or something
like that so they could they they cancel
that location
yeah they only had a couple days left
that's when they found Altamonte the guy
out there getting Bill Carter somebody
off this place
so they ended up moving everything there
in a big hurry
so he moved everything to Altamonte and
there wasn't they didn't move everything
because there was no concession stands
there was no nothing it was just a it
wasn't even the racetrack was right next
to the racetrack ultimate is east of the
city yeah Eastern Market is up by uh
going south right there in fact that
section of the freeway wasn't even open
yet at that time it was a department
where you get for the parking lot
basically
anyway so that's very uh
advice everyone in the background that's
where emotion was at then uh and uh
so anyway uh that's where they ended up
having the things done at but there
wasn't any and there was no I mean there
was no concession stands at all and
nothing people were people coming from
uh 20 miles away parking trying to find
spots people it was like it was really
crazy like I said three other thousand
people in this little tiny area
and uh
I don't even know how many outhouses he
had maybe 50 that many
and you know those are over full by
three o'clock five o'clock you know
anyway in the daytime there was not much
there there was no no food stamps no
nothing people got there got there early
they walked for miles and parked their
cars and people's farms and [__]
a lot of people there A lot of people
came early and then they a lot of people
are an acid bad acid and stuff like that
so it was pretty you know a lot of
people were crazy if they're in front a
lot of people in the back area they've
had a pretty good time but people really
find didn't want to give up the spot
they were they wouldn't even a place to
sit down
future if your body sleeping bags or
anything with you and you set it down
anyway you got a shot again you know
just got many people there
anyway so
he's got to be uh
uh pretty intense for a while because
people started climbing up on the stage
like it was like it'd be like for hours
like a zombie attack yeah because they
come up with their look in their eyes
you know they're coming on there
and uh
and that's where some of the violence
started coming from because people were
getting crazy we had to get crazy with
them
and that's the only way they would back
off
so that's uh that's where most of the
day went so most of yesterday was going
on during the daytime
and uh
because uh they didn't see what's going
on they still just saw the violence and
they started yelling or whatever guys
and he built and he and he told me you
know
you know these guys put this one
together he said that so
let you guys do it yourself
so then then we decided to not do that
because some of the guys didn't want to
go upstairs so we weren't going to leave
our guys alone up there so we came back
there's a lot of guys in the audience
and stuff like that but but there were
you know some of us are on the stage and
uh keeping people off the stage was was
a big project you know it's got to be
more
scary than you might think you know but
uh in fact in fact there was one point
where I heard a girl screaming and she's
been trampled by the front of the stage
and people just taking care less they're
just trying to get a better view I
prestige is only like this high
anyway so I jumped down there and
started knock these people off this girl
picked her up and uh
probably saved your life I guess but
then but there was other incidents like
that that went on with other people you
know like so later on the day the
department of Marty balance when he when
he when he uh
uh emergency when he got punched yeah so
everybody
remembers of Parker yeah and so I
remember
knock them out anyway so that's where uh
every yard got freaked out but the bands
got scared dude
but we got it all straightened out after
that murder Ballin of Jefferson you know
then the show continued on pretty good
for the day
yeah there's there's Marty Belling of
the Jefferson Airplane Jefferson
Airplane yeah
he wasn't unfortunate but but we didn't
get it bad but uh so later on today I
guess uh you know we're getting towards
the evening remember this is December
it's cold it's it gets dark at six
o'clock at night in fact sure I know
what people have been there all day some
people from the day before
and so some people didn't know where
their families are at where their cart
or anything but now it's getting cold
getting dark
and the grateful they were supposed to
come on
and they got off the helicopter
and people are coming to run a field oh
the hell's into the craziest beating up
everybody's musicians they got scared
and get back in the helicopter and left
meantime the Rolling Stones are sitting
back in a tent behind the stage killing
time waiting for their time right and
there's no music for almost 45 minutes
they're really stories had the guy on
the stage trying to warm the crowd up
and but this time it was getting really
intense so that's where we uh we're in
the back and I told him you know you
guys
get out there and yeah so you don't need
to warm that ground up anymore people
get out there and do it now because
they're not gonna be responsible for
your life until they do that
and uh
so thank you when I started the show
and uh and as a side note in that tent
there was boxes and boxes this big
crates of turkey drumsticks all cooked
just tons of them and people out there
starving their food and you probably so
we had to grabbing all these boxes of uh
turkey dumpsticks and playing them out
and started throwing them out to the
crowd you know we also throwing beer out
to the crowd too but
but uh uh we had a couple people
complained they got hit in there with a
beer so
[Applause]
but so anyway there was a
we got him on stage and they started
playing it meantime this other guy this
guy this uh
uh been him uh forget his name Mary
Snyder he he'd been put off the stage
two or three times and he was getting
kind of crazy
and he went and hit judged up and
finished testimony and he ended up uh
walked two miles to his car got his gun
he came back walked to the stage and
started shooting at it
he actually one of our guys actually got
shot in the arm
you're gonna see that in the movie and
that shot but that's what happened yeah
uh
uh anyway when he started doing that one
of our members in the audience
shot and
he put a knife on him
and ended up a bunch of people I mean
the guy was a guy ended up dying
from you know active shooter you know
nowadays
we put up with all the time nowadays
people were active Shooters discovered
an active shooter he was actually trying
to see that um that uh
what's your name
it's Mick Jagger Mick Jagger
and uh
yeah we didn't see that but you know
many stories people have Twisted it
around saying all kinds of stuff about
what happened there
said to it
yeah the violence that happened it was
unfortunate but it could have been a lot
worse
because uh
there's one scene in there we see one of
our prospects with a with a procure
being on some bad guy turns out the
story behind that one is the Pokey or
the king he was using because because he
had a bad thing in a caster and this guy
he was stabbed in the leg or something
he got beat up just being a
swap you know anyway and uh
so uh
it wasn't like there was a minister
there could have been beat up this guy
was actually you know good Bonanza
women's [__]
anyway so
uh
there was that and afterwards we ended
up leaving the
if things wrapped up and
and there was that for Optima for the
history books here what was what was
your favorite decade
you've been you've been a biker for many
decades now huh what was your favorite
decade
and a favorite decade nevermind I love
them all right thank you you know
talking about decades I mean the 60s was
great the 50s is great I mean being a
kid
life was so much super there you know
and yeah when you get three out at night
time your kids could walk to school and
not have to worry about getting
robbed mugged or murdered or you can
leave the door unlocked in front of your
house
and there was a good day sir
so what does it mean to be a Hell's
Angels biker yeah
to me
peace my life you know what I'm saying
uh
your brothers all over the world I'd
love to visit them
and visit their countries visit their
where they live
you know sightseeing and see all the
cool stuff around it to see in this
world
and it's like you get to see everywhere
where you go it's like there's different
cultures and they're all they've all got
color you know it's a it's an
interesting game
and at the same time we also
we have a bond that's basically mad
Brotherhood you know
it's like uh
kind of like the warrior Creed you know
it's like
yeah and uh you know
and you know just everybody's just
trying to survive in this world with the
uh dealing with these governments we
have to deal with yeah the oppressive
government too we have you know
and uh
just like everybody in our communities
and
and uh
anywhere we're at people where we live
is our communities and
and uh
we interact with our communities you
know
like some places we uh
we have to we have toy runs every year
for under privileged kids and stuff and
other places we would do other benefits
for different things like cancer and
stuff but yeah mostly we have motorcycle
riders you know that's what we do
Central Key and then we have Brotherhood
and that's what it's all about
and uh
um you've done prison time at that
prison time
and I was set up by the fancy trying to
get me for a couple years
and then if I ended up you're going to
jail for for drugs
for a couple years and
they proud of that
Facebook for my time and for
manufacturing or selling no selling
selling yeah it was crystal
methamphetamine and cocaine honestly and
uh
this is mostly because my credibility
was good to me but really good I was
able to I want to make sure that people
my friends were there doing it were
doing any poison
so I made sure they had you know sure
since I was
yeah
you know I dabbled in it for a few years
and it never got greedy so it never
really made a lot of money or anything I
just went I just
a motorcycle mechanic did you ever use
it yeah I used to use
I've never had it never abused it
you're a kid right you have kids yes
you're married
I'm married once
yeah and your sons your sons are members
of I got two of them yeah of oaklands as
well yeah
yeah one started his own Charter and
ready okay so yeah and uh
I proud of them
runs in the family your dad yeah you and
your sons yeah
the Hell's Angels are a notorious
motorcycle gang club
but uh okay we re-emphasize that because
uh this same gang Street gang is like uh
Fibonacci case
yeah we're motorcycle club but basically
like a fraternity
you know and uh
and and we're probably one of the most
democratic organizations around
so if we vote on everything and uh
who don't condone distracted a lot of
stuff guys get into we don't be doing
that stuff that's why a lot of guys but
you're not completely innocent either
yeah well we kick out people in the club
that too dark
okay at the same time we uh we also back
each other up
do you have any regrets in your life
perfectly happy in my life
what's your biggest fear now you're
seven you're 73 73 what's your biggest
fear now
do you sphere
is there a German nuclear war I guess
that's a good one
you should all be afraid of that yeah
yeah you've been alive before oh yeah
it's quite a few times
and you can love more than one woman at
a time too
sure because I have 300 mothers for
three for my kids you know
and I'm still friends with one they're
still alive yeah
you know I've lived a few of them they
were younger than me
how does being a member of the Hell's
Angels impact your
your personal life
it must in some way right huh it must
impact your life in some way well it's
uh your reputation just like
my reputation is pretty is pretty good
actually yeah you're probably not one of
the most trouble
biggest troublemakers right no
but I do keep some of them in line
you already that I was president in
Frisco for a while and we were and I
worked on setting up our Corporation to
register our trademarks and
yeah
protect our patch
because there's years goes by you know
you'll get people pretending to be us
and it caused a lot of problems a lot of
heat we get is from people out there
acting like
and it's not true
what are you proudest of in your life
priority
proudest of uh
Mr Club has grown
the fridge I run as well it's still
going strong still Yes over 400 Chargers
in the world
over 40 countries and I've been quite a
few of them
still trying to finish my world tour
and these are going to be driving the
roads it's going to be an impossible
task
the
like this picture you took yesterday
official here
yeah years ago yeah that was 20 years
ago let's just go Cisco and um Cisco of
Valderrama and Marvin Gilbert right yeah
two of the most awesome members you ever
met tell me about Cisco and Marvin
Cisco is uh he's the president right
imagine he's he's actually born in LA
I knew he was born in San Francisco they
raised in L.A here he used to climb me a
lot when I was in Frisco before I
transferred to Oakland and then I come
to find out he was actually born in
Frisco he was one of the most he was one
of the more notorious members right yeah
no tourists but he never went to prison
you know he was very when he was he set
up uh Charlie mcgoo Productions which uh
Willie Nelson shows and and uh
everything else in the nuts Merle
Haggard and they they did the first big
concert for bringing us in that at the
San Francisco Opera House
I mean it's like this it's the big shows
they did and uh
that's all part of our music music that
was interactive with in the club over
the years
all right
and Marvin and Cisco are both passed
away now uh Marvin and Cisco have both
passed away they both passed away here
Marvin
he was really challenging individual but
he was a he was crazy at least
a character I mean he uh wrote a bunch
of stories searched uh share stories and
uh
suddenly used a lot of some of his
stories in his first book
you know and uh
probably tell more about Marvin by
reading these stories yeah because he
even got a story about his his life
story based on
uh when he was a kid
and uh
and uh it's really interesting
but he used to mentioned for years he
never even had more driver's license
but he still sometimes he was entirely
his belt buckle for his ID
you know every time he got in trouble
and when the judge told uh where the
judge gave him probation with only one
condition as long as certainly was his
with his probation officer basically
he's not under 20 supervision because
you know certainly would keep him out of
trouble
yeah what do the Hell's Angels look for
in a new member would would get somebody
in what keeps them out
you're going to be real
you have to have a motorcycle
and uh
they are you know
get us an integrity
you know you gotta
you know you come around you guys get to
get to know each other and
you know it's not for everybody
it takes a lot of commitment
and uh
you know she had a lot of a lot of good
guys come and go this guy's a guy
tragically other guys have
got kicked out and
and
it's like
our words are Bond that's the main thing
thank you we trust each other
in fact what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
uh just honor
and like I said he says value honor well
yeah the only thing you take with you is
your honor
so many people in the world can't look
in the mirror because they betrayed
people they cared about you know
it's like one thing we don't do we don't
betray each other without
yeah that's right some of a lot of our
rules were involves the drugs and stuff
back in the 60s working people would
come to town for another for another
town to where and they start robbing
people or start thinking they can burn
people because they use their patch
well that was totally against our
[__] rules it's like we need that's
where a lot of our rules are about to
keep our keeping our integrity
Yes actually you don't go use the
passive bullying people and I mean it
happens
but we're doing a lot when we find out
about it but uh
but uh
uh you know when you have when you got
this uh
the wide variety of men in the world
you can find you know you'll find
somebody that makes your image
if I was Angel if there's some you know
you might think he's a scary guy because
you got to meet that manage and the
other guy it might be media
we're all individuals
and uh
we only want the best for each other
all right flash thank you so much for
sharing your story all right I wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you